nearly a year since her son's death
and now the possibility of justice
there might be a chance that i'll be
able to fulfill my promise
to my boy um sooner rather than later
a glimmer of hope from a letter written
by the lord chancellor
saying holding a trial virtually or in
absentee
are being considered for the suspect in
harry dunn's death
his mother has this message for the
attorney general
if it's the only way forward and the
only feasible way that we can get her
through the justice system
to just please work
as hard as you would if it was one of
your own children
to get this done we need this closure
nineteen-year-old harry dunn died after
his motorbike crashed into a car
outside an raf base in northamptonshire
last august
the american woman wanted over his death
and succules
claimed diplomatic immunity and traveled
back to the united states
despite a visit to president trump by
harry dunn's family
u.s authorities have since refused an
extradition request
but legal experts say a virtual trial in
the uk
would be unprecedented if the defendant
doesn't come
then the judge can only go ahead if the
judge thinks it will be fair
and most judges would say it would not
be fair to try somebody in their absence
because they can't respond to the
evidence they can't give evidence
themselves
they can't suggest questions to their
lawyers
it's almost a show trial if somebody's
tried when they're not there
charlotte's also fighting for a judicial
review against the foreign office
over legal boundaries for diplomatic
immunity
she says no matter the outcome she will
never give up
it doesn't take any thought or strength
at all
to muster up determination is naturally
there
we need to just keep fighting if we have
to do that then we will if i have to
make it a life's work
i will as the anniversary of harry
dunn's death approaches on thursday
his family simply want closure and
justice
is the only way adele robinson sky news